[Music]
Philippine president Ferdinand Marcos Jr
is set to meet President Biden for his
first White House visit on Monday
officials here in Manila say there are
two key things president Marcos wants to
address the first is trade deepening
economic cooperation and the second is
defense
the Biden Administration says the
bilateral meeting will reaffirm the US's
Ironclad commitment to the defense of
the Philippines
and it comes on the heels of large-scale
joint military exercises amid growing
Regional tension with China
since 1951 the Philippines and the U.S
have shared a mutual defense treaty
which obliges the U.S to help defend the
Asian Nation you hear about that a lot
on the ground here they call it the MDT
it means that if the Philippines is
attacked the U.S is expected to defend
it and if the U.S has attacked the
Philippines is expected to come to the
US's defense
the Philippines is Washington's oldest
treaty Ally in Asia and it's in a
strategically important location for the
U.S its northernmost Islands lie close
to Taiwan and its West Coast borders the
South China Sea a Waterway through which
trillions of dollars in trade pass each
year
even though Washington and Manila have
been long-standing security Partners the
relationship has had its highs and lows
[Applause]
marcos's predecessor Rodrigo duterte who
served as president from 2016 to 2022
expressed distrust of Washington and
threatened to unravel the key U.S
relationship
this will be the last maneuver
what games between the United States
and the Philippines
military
then
in the fullness of God's time
I am president for six years
no more
I want to be friend to China
during duterte's tenure he drew the
Philippines closer to Beijing he visited
China early in his term hosted Xi
Jinping in the Philippines and boasted
of a rapport with the Chinese president
towards the end of his administration he
seemed to realize that the people of the
Philippines did not support that because
China was not backing down from things
that the Philippines see as a threat to
their sovereignty
the Philippines security establishment
ultimately persuaded him to soften his
stance toward the U.S which supports
manila's territorial claims in the South
China Sea since Marcos took office in
June last year he's increased
cooperation with the U.S Philippine
military officials say Marcos removed
curbs on their interaction with the U.S
military that were imposed by duterte
the White House meeting comes days after
the two countries wrapped up military
exercises called balakitan which
included live fire drills and more than
17 500 troops these exercises happen
every year but this was by far the
biggest balcattan ever it was a huge
show of force for the first time the
exercises included a focus on the
defense of the northern Philippines and
preparations for conflict if China tries
to take Taiwan by force
these drills followed Chinese military
exercises in the region that the state
broadcaster said were intended to
practice establishing an aerial blockade
of Taiwan which Beijing claims as part
of China
foreign
in an effort to counter China's
influence the U.S reached an agreement
with the Philippines in February that
nearly doubled the number of sites that
the U.S military can use in the country
that's just part of our efforts to
modernize our alliance
and these efforts are especially
important as a People's Republic of
China continues to advance its
illegitimate claims in the west
Philippine Sea
the deal falls under the country's
enhanced defense cooperation agreement
which dates back to 2014 and allows the
U.S to build facilities at agreed upon
Philippine bases the U.S used some of
those facilities in the drills this year
not everyone is in favor of stronger
ties with the U.S some people in the
Philippines are worried that the
Philippines is putting itself in the
middle of a battle between two
superpowers China is one of the
Philippines largest trading partners
further complicating the picture and
forcing the Philippine leader to walk a
fine line between the two countries
one item of business between the leaders
at the White House could be whether
Manila will be purchasing heimar's
weapon systems as part of an upgrade of
its military after Marcos watched
demonstrations during the balakattan
exercises the U.S Air Force said on
Tuesday it would revive joint jet
fighter training exercises with the
Philippines for the first time since
1990. a further sign of deepening
military ties I actually asked
Philippine officials and U.S officials
how they would describe the relationship
status and they seem to be very eager to
expand on some of the progress that has
been made in the past few months
foreign
[Music]